this morning where we are standing by
for remarks from the elizabeth warren
assistant to the president special
advisor to Treasury secretary Geithner
Thank You Raj it really is a treat to be
here today at our first conference and a
conference that so fittingly is about
data and about measuring the effect of a
new set of rules on a part of the credit
industry so um one year ago today many
provisions of the credit card
accountability and disclosure act the
card act took effect we come together on
this anniversary uh to mark the event
but our primary goal is to analyze and
discuss the impact of the card act at
the new Consumer Financial Protection
Bureau as Raj said we are determined
that any actions we take will be
grounded in a deep understanding of the
market we are overseeing our
organization reflects this commitment
research and rule writing are brought
together in a single division in the new
Bureau comprising five expert teams in
specific market areas the card markets
team was one of the first to get
underway and this conference represents
the kind of work we plan to do on an
ongoing basis one year after the card
act took effect we think it is
appropriate to ask whether it had its
intended effects and how the credit card
marketplace has changed as a consequence
of this new law where there are clear
causal links we need to draw them out
and where the connections are more
tenuous we need to keep asking questions
and analyzing data of course we must
recognize the limits of this approach
public policy formulations cannot be put
on hold until every question has a
definitive answer the data will always
be limited and the answers will never be
definitive even so we will work to
formulate policy based on evidence and
rigorous analysis this conference is
important to the agency our work with
you today can help inform the way the
new consumer bureau will approach the
credit card market we hope to leave here
today with a better understanding of the
policy implications of what the data
show and how to frame the research
questions that remain to be answered now
when the act was signed into law in May
2009 it was clear that the credit card
market was in need of serious reform
Congress concluded that certain
practices in the credit card industry
were not fair and transparent to
consumers and the card Act passed with
very strong bipartisan support in both
the House and the Senate as predators
President Obama said when he signed the
card Act into law the act was intended
to uphold quote basic standards of
fairness transparency and accountability
the concerns that gave rise to the Act
were not about the profitability of the
credit card industry but rather the
methods used to generate some of those
profits pricing had become too opaque
some issuers advertised an understated
price up front counting on interest
rates repricing fees penalties and other
often unexpected charges on the back to
let the company charge an overall higher
price than the consumer had anticipated
the harm to customers was significant
but the harm to competition was also
substantial some issuers explained that
when they made improvements in cards
potential customers could not tell so
for example when one of the largest
issuers in the market dropped universal
default clauses amid much fanfare the
cards were still so complex that the
customers could not tell within a few
months the company reversed course
reinstituting universal default so the
card act was designed to reduce
surprises in the repricing of a cow
and to take a major step in improving
the overall transparency of credit card
costs as a result of the card Act
consumers now have better information
about how much they're paying for credit
and how much they might save on interest
if they pay down their balances more
quickly than they might otherwise have
planned thanks to the card act there are
no more shifting due dates and customers
have at least 21 days to make their
payments both of which should make it
less likely that they will be hit with
unexpected late fees a year later the
card Act has brought about major changes
in the way the industry operates in part
this is attributable to the protections
Congress enacted but the data we have
assembled indicate that much of the
industry has gone further than the law
requires in reap in curbing repricing
and over-limit fees a number of issuers
have eliminated some of the practices
that can confuse customers and cost them
money they reasonably did not expect to
pay lenders in the industry deserve
credit for moving in the right direction
of course not everyone embraced this
approach as soon as the card act became
law it seems that some industry lawyers
were asked to find slightly different
ways to accomplish that which the law
was intended to prohibit to its credit
the Federal Reserve Board responded with
a rulemaking proceeding designed to
close the loopholes while I doubt that
anyone thinks this is the last time such
a rulemaking proceeding will be required
we can probably agree that this approach
write a rule avoid a rule write another
rule and so on is costly for consumers
and costly for the industry because it
multiplies the number and complexity of
rules this approach creates special
challenges for those smaller banks and
credit issuers that still offer credit
cards to their customers I believe the
card Act has pushed in the right
direction it has brought about
significant reforms in both the pricing
practices of credit issuers and the
information provided to consumers even
so
substantial challenges remain thinking
about the approach to regulation and how
to improve markets without an
over-reliance on rules will be our next
challenge we all believe in we've all
experienced the benefits of competition
when markets work well in efficient
producers and shoddy products are more
likely to fall of their own weight with
competition consumers tend to get
improved product choices and lower
prices competition may also increase the
rewards to firms that innovate in ways
that consumers value but for a market
system to fully serve the interests of
consumers consumers need to be able to
understand the costs benefits and risks
of alternative products and to be able
to compare those products straight up by
this standard in the credit card market
we have more work to do and the task is
formidable even with the improvements
brought about by the card act there are
a lot of moving parts in a credit card
price despite the important progress
made in improving the Schumer box
disclosure and monthly statements um it
is still difficult for many consumers to
understand the costs and risks of each
individual credit card or to compare
cards directly our next challenges will
be about further clarifying price and
risk and making it easier for consumers
to make direct product comparisons our
new consumer bureau will make clarity a
top priority industry representatives
have expressed their willingness to help
and many consumer groups and academics
are committed to helping as well we want
to work collaboratively with all parties
a part of that collaboration we want to
be sure that we understand the
consequences of the card act both
intended and unintended this conference
is a first step in that direction so I
anticipate that today's event will
provoke some thoughtful and informed
discussions about
what has changed since the card act took
effect and what those changes mean for
consumers issuers and the market and
what remains to be done that is the most
fitting way to commemorate this one-year
anniversary it is also the right way to
launch a new conversation that uses our
collective brainpower to advance a
fairer and more efficient market so
thank you again for your time and your
energy thank you for being here today we
need you thank you